the only single dose cova 19 vac has
arrived
thousands of doses of johnson and
johnson's newest vaccine now in the
hands of the southern nevada health
district
christian joins us in studio with where
they will be distributed
and whether one is essentially better
than another christian well kirsten
health officials say you should not hold
off from any vaccine brand
to get a specific one because all three
are safe and reliable some information
you should know about the johnson and
johnson vaccine
is that it's known as the jansen vaccine
it's the first single
dose that will be distributed to
hospitals and clinics in southern nevada
more than fifteen thousand doses of this
vaccine were delivered today
direct comparison of all the vaccines
cannot be made
because clinical trials were conducted
during different times during today's
update with health officials they
stressed
all three vaccines medurna pfizer and
johnson and johnson
are safe move forward i think
when in terms of choice the best that we
can do um is to really just be very
transparent
about a an event or a pod or
whatever appointment is appointments are
available um in specific locations
and then be able to um show which
product will be available
health officials added covet testing is
down in nevada because they say there is
less demand from the public
to get tested because of the vaccine
availability many of the testing sites
are also
now being used for vaccine distribution
one other note they mentioned
an increase in rapid covet testing and
those results
are not being captured in the daily
updates an issue
they say they're working on christian
casadas 8 news now